one of the most exciting things about
the Multiverse Saga and Avengers Secret
Wars is the possibility and probability
that the OG Avengers are going to return
in fact we've heard many different
insiders state that Robert Downey Jr's
Iron Man and Chris Evans as Captain
America are indeed going to be returning
in Avengers Secret Wars now just to
clarify these are indeed going to be
variants of the characters based off of
everything that we heard Iron Man isn't
going to be resurrected and Captain
America isn't going to kind of have time
flow through him to make him young again
but these will just be variants from
other universes played by Robert Downey
Jr and Chris Evans so they can come back
for Avengers Secret Wars yes it's fan
service but it also makes a ton of sense
to do we have seen a lot of different
characters in their variant at this
point and since so many ogs are coming
back for Deadpool 3 and Avengers Secret
Wars and maybe some other movies or
shows in between it would make sense to
have the Iron Man and the Captain
America return we haven't heard much
about Black Widow but hopefully Scarlett
Johansson returns and reprises her role
as that character as well but one thing
a lot of people haven't been talking
about is the villains this isn't just a
prime opportunity to have some of the
heroes return but villains are going to
be returning as well so you thought
Ultron was gone but it looks like we
could see him in secret Wars same thing
with Thanos we thought Avengers ing game
could have been the complete end of
Thanos ever appearing in the MCU again
but we did see him briefly and although
he was dead in dror strange in the
Multiverse of Madness however in secret
Wars we could see him alive once again
in fact we could be seeing some lowkey
variants pop up in Avengers Secret Wars
as well and this isn't limited just to
Avengers Secret Wars but they could also
appear in Deadpool 3 and what's really
interesting about the premise of how
these villains could return to the MCU
is that we could see multiple variants
of them and they could be incredibly bad
still or they might actually be good and
have to fight with the heroes to defeat
King the Conqueror but one thing seems
to be for sure at this point in time and
that is that Marvel Studios is planning
on introducing battle world to the m and
based off of what we know it sounds like
this is going to start in Deadpool 3 and
ultimately end in Avengers Secret Wars
so we'll tell you everything you need to
know about what's going to happen in
this video and if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest MCU news and if you
subscribe and leave a comment you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for chance to win a PS5 an Xbox series X
some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner picks one item and we
pick one winner at the end of every
single month so right away let me know
who you would love to see return as far
as villains are concerned a lot of
people would love to see Thanos but a
lot of people thought that Ultron really
was done dirty just getting one movie
being defeated and then that was the end
of it now we did get infinity Ultron and
wh if and maybe there will be some type
of connection to the animated what if
series especially after season 2 but as
far as live action goes fans were really
disappointed that Ultron was done after
Age of Ultron but it doesn't look like
he is and that could actually be in a
couple of different ways there have been
rumors going around for a while now that
Ultron could possibly make a return for
armor Wars armor Wars is going to be
about what if Tony Stark Tech gets in
the wrong hands well Ultron technically
is Tony startech and as of right now
we're not really sure if any remnants of
Ultron remain anywhere but I'm assuming
they do somewhere in all of the data
that Tony Stark had and we know that the
department of damage control did take a
lot of Tony Stark Tech what happened to
that and how did it get into the wrong
hands so we know that he could come back
in armor Wars but as far as battle World
goes we are most likely seeing a variant
of Ultron From Another Universe now keep
in mind in Multiverse of Madness we did
see the Ultron Bots which means Ultron
exists somewhere in that universe or he
did and perhaps the Illuminati defeated
him or perhaps since they have
successfully created the Ultron Bots
perhaps Tony Stark and Bruce Banner or
whoever maybe with the help of Reed
Richards got it right in that universe
and created a good Ultron and that most
likely did happen in some Universe in
the Multiverse which is the really cool
thing about Deadpool 3 Secret Wars and
just the Multiverse Saga in general is
that variant of characters can show up
and they could be the opposite of what
we know about them Ultron could show up
on battle world and he could be good
same thing with Thanos I mean we've seen
what if we have seen how a few different
changes can drastically alter history
and this is what is being set up in the
MCU right now which is really exciting
now it's supposed to start with Deadpool
3 if you haven't heard Deadpool 3 is
essentially going to be the beginning of
battle world and the TVA is supposed to
play a pretty significant role in
Deadpool 3 not only are Wolverine and
Deadpool going to be in the TVA both as
prisoners but of course they break out
and they steal TVA technology and start
to travel the Multiverse well keep in
mind Deadpool 3 does exist in the whole
picture of the MCU the overall story of
the Multiverse so while they're doing
their own thing the Multiverse is
beginning to kind of collapse incursions
are happening everywhere and Kang and
all of the king variants are trying to
take over the Multiverse at the same
time based off of what we've heard from
insiders universes throughout the
Multiverse are going to begin dying and
King the Conqueror and all of his
variants are going to be behind the
Multiverse almost being destroyed so the
TVA is going to go to a bunch of
different universes and they are going
to pick a bunch of different Heroes and
possibly some villains and bring them
all to one place essentially this is
going to be a battle world now the goal
for this is so they could all come
together to ultimately defeat King the
Conqueror and all of his variants this
is how we get multiversal Avengers team
but more recently since we've had all of
these changes with Jonathan major being
found guilty and Marvel Studios firing
him and the future of King the Conqueror
kind of unknown right now we've heard a
lot of talks from insiders stating that
there is going to be sort of a bigger
villain than Kang the Conqueror now most
insiders believe that this is still
going to be a beyonder variant of Kang
and that we are still going to have a
battle world now it's not going to be
just like the comics because of course
the MCU never does that they take
inspiration but they never do it exactly
like the comics do it but in the comics
the beyonder essentially separates the
heroes and the villains and says go at
it fight each other I'll Grant the
winner whatever they want this could be
what we're looking at in the MCU
regardless of how it happens we are
going to get heroes and villains in one
place and we all know what happens when
you put heroes and villains in one place
well they tend to fight the TVA might go
around Gathering all of the potential
superheroes or super people or mutants
or whatever they think are going to be
useful to defeat Kang in battle but they
might have forgotten how much these
characters can Clash with one another
even good characters can Clash with
other good characters Tony Stark is
actually kind of the perfect example a
genius with a very specific personality
running into himself you know that they
would all want to be the better variant
of Tony Stark and could definitely Clash
especially if one is comparing
technology with the other what if one is
further along in time and has much
better Iron Man Tech than another would
have basically this could lead to a lot
of conflict not only between heroes and
villains but between Heroes and heroes
and villains and villains and according
to Insider can we get some toast there
is going to be sort of a fake portal
scene a parody portal scene in Deadpool
3 that is a parody of the portal scene
from Avengers ingame this is going to be
sort of a multiversal portal scene where
we will see like I mentioned heroes and
villains and in this scene in particular
we could see The Return of Voltron of
Thanos we could see Loki and as I
mentioned before we could see good
versions of King the Conqueror
technically from what we saw in Loki
season 2 Victor timley was indeed a good
King variant but he wasn't really King
the Conqueror hopefully we do see a full
King the Conqueror with all of the king
Tech who is good that would definitely
help out the Avengers but if you thought
some of these OG villains were gone and
we' never see them again well enter the
Multiverse Saga some rumors going around
suggest they are going to return but
also it just makes sense that they would
return and it would be a really big
missed opportunity for Marvel Studios to
not at least have some of these villains
return as cameos and Multiverse of
Madness kind of brought back Thanos and
Ultron with the Ultron Bots and well
dead Thanos and also not to mention we
could of course get villains that have
not entered the MCU yet it's been said
that we are going to see mutants that we
haven't seen yet whether that be in the
fox universe or the MCU now and we're
supposed to get a lot of different
Wolverine variants as well even if these
are just slight cameos so it's exciting
enough that Marvel Studios is planning
on bringing back some of the original
X-Men characters but when you think
about how big secret Wars and Deadpool 3
and everything else in between could be
with the Multiverse truly breaking down
and universes colliding things start to
get really exciting when you think about
all of the possibilities that could
happen and of course like we've been
mentioning some of the possibilities are
these villains that we have known and
loved could possibly return and even
maybe get a better Redemption Arc like
Ultron because you have to imagine that
some of these villains might want to
actually join Kang and helped take over
the Multiverse only to try and overthrow
him later on down the road that
definitely sounds like something Victor
Von Doom would do which is exactly what
happens in the comics with him and the
beyonder so with everything and anything
being possible right now in the MCU let
me know what you would love to see in
the comments down below and which
villain would you be the most excited
about returning in deool 3 or Secret
Wars let us know in the comments down
below please don't forget to like the
video and subscribe to the channel to
stay up to date on the MCU you can find
us on Instagram and Twitter if you'd
like and as always thank you all so much
for watching woof
woof